all right guys you want to see something
really messed up uh yes I might not be
working for corridor much longer I have
to just just take a look at this so in
to this program I provided just footage
of an actor and I said make this person
an alien okay what does that mean and an
alien it made him oh yeah look at that
oh wow dude it's like
nearly perfect it doesn't look like I
did zero effects work on this I I
clicked a button I said make him an
alien an hour later it's Pat this out
it's nuts because I'm looking at this
and I'm thinking every step that would
go into actually doing this I mean all
of it would take an astronomical amount
of time you need to do a ton of prep
asset gathering on set so you're saying
you literally just click a a single
button and it does all of it it might be
like three buttons oh then I'm not you
know what it's three buttons
one by one appearing you know how many
button clicks this took to achieve this
effect I have an idea
three
that's that's exactly correct isn't this
so jacked up that this exists yeah the
reason we specifically have stopped
making videos like this is because the
last one took months
[Applause]
the freaking boss Town Dynamics videos
we spent weeks just painting out Clint
it's just a one-click solution to our CG
characters and you know I have a history
of making shorts with CG characters
[Music]
my short film called scooty which came
out on Corridor and that film features a
full CG character throughout the
entirety of the short film and that took
me about three years to complete because
for all of the 200 shots that had that
CG character I would have to first onset
record the person doing their
performance then ask them to leave the
frame get The Clean Plate of the
background to then put the CG character
over then record the motion capture
bring the CG character in track the
footage so we get the right camera
movement and then add extra animations
for their face and eyes and everything
relight that render it out put it into
After Effects composite it match the
color saturation blah blah it took like
maybe a day or two days per shot and now
it's just one button and I did all of
these shots in an afternoon so Peter how
many shots in scooty I think there were
about 200 visual effects shots
oh dude should I even show this to him
no it'll break his heart show me show me
it would have taken you eight days
genuinely how does this make you feel
you know I don't know whether I should
be mad or excited or scared I've spent
my whole life doing this you know this
is my professional career and that part
of me is like God damn did I waste all
my time here but the 14 year old in me
is so pumped about this like if I had
this when I was a kid and I was running
around making movies with my friends I
would just unlimit my creativity at that
time the reality is if you could make
scooty without any of this like how much
more are you now capable of if you were
given a week I mean it said what eight
days do you think that in one week you
could make a short that features CG
characters I mean I hope so if if the
answer is yes that's going to open the
door to so much unbridled creativity
next week we got a whole short film with
a full CG cast of characters I think a
week from Friday you will be able to sit
down and watch a whole short film with
CG characters I I want I want on my desk
a whole short film full of CG characters
all right in one week I'll burn it to a
Blu-ray and smack it down on your desk
will it take longer for you to burn the
Blu-ray than it will for you to do the
visual effects for the short especially
the last time I burned a disc was from
idvd in 2007 and that took about 12
hours so I I think maybe yes
[Music]
I'm excited for Peter to get started on
this because Peter he has a very
specific personality if you've seen any
of our rendered challenges you'll know
exactly what I'm talking about
day to do it you're like I'm gonna make
a movie Peter has a perfectionist
personality and generally it's kind of
nice and I love when people really put
passion into their work and they exceed
expectations but discipline and
restraint those are two incredibly
important aspects you need to be
practicing as an artist Nico and myself
within the first year of us running this
YouTube channel we did a year basically
of saying hey let's do a video every two
weeks as much passion as we have for
making art in order to support ourselves
doing it we have to be very cognizant of
how fast we can achieve things or else
suddenly we're spending months years on
projects so it's a huge challenge for
Peter he's incredibly talented I
sincerely hope he can pull it off
because if there is any tool that's
going to allow them to do it it's this
Peter said at the end of this process he
will deliver me a Blu-ray disc so he's
going to have to finish this project and
make sure he's allotting enough time for
him to figure out how he's going to get
this onto physical media as well in fact
I'm going to make a space right here
this is going to be where he puts that
disc and if this is not here when the
deadline hits he has failed
[Music]
pitch me your story pretend like I'm a
very important producer we're in an
elevator time's ticking away okay how
many floors do I have uh let's say let's
say six okay so it's about three sibling
aliens on a road trip across the US and
their UFO and they run out of it no I'm
just doing one by one I'm doing one by
one anyways so they run out of food they
got to stop at a farmhouse and avoid
getting caught while they pick up more
food for their adventure and you're
you're up to the challenge I think it's
going to be great I'm very excited about
this new software and I'm hoping it lets
me achieve my dreams in an insane amount
of time you're gonna be fine I have so
much faith that you're gonna you're
gonna pull this off man I gotta be
honest it's been like a year since I've
picked up a cinema camera dude I've been
working on a freaking video game the
last year I haven't made any movies I'm
making a VR game it's gonna be super
sweet it's called hard shot you can
check it out or whatever I wonder if
that director shooter and muscle has
atrophied a little bit I'm honestly a
little worried about it but I'm gonna
make sure I got my skills up to par we
got lenses we got batteries and media we
got the camera out there everything is
ready to go and all we have to do now is
make the goddamn thing
[Music]
a lot of uh anxiety going on right here
just gotta tell it you know it's okay to
be there a little tip for you if you
want to calm down really quickly just do
a few of these you do a big breath in
hold it and then a little bit more
ooh flip that out do that like five
times it'll calm you right down and
everybody make a movie
it takes a little bit of the pressure
off to to know that I'm gonna be fully
covered up you know even if my
performance is bad he can just redo the
keyframes on the 3D rig and then he can
make it look like I was a good actor and
so for me that's kind of best case
scenario none of that even has to be
kept
yeah that's perfect awesome let's move
on so shooting with Wonder Dynamics I
don't really have to worry that much
about VFX but I also have to be very
cognizant of the fact that it has its
limitations I've used Wonder Dynamics a
little bit you know just through the
beta and some random tests but I don't
really know where the quirks lie and
everything and so I got to be careful
not to let anything obscure Austin
here's hoping that everything works out
I honestly don't know
we're in the studio today on the easiest
day of filming ever had I mean the first
day was the hard day we were on set we
were under time constraints but today is
going to be super chill
[Music]
what we're getting today we're not even
getting shots
we're basically getting a visual mocap
today because all this that we're
filming today is going to take place in
UFO and so what we're really getting is
the performance so that later we can
take the blender file that it gives you
during its processing and put our UFO
background into that file and then once
it's in blender I'll take my CG camera
and I'll do the cool like Steven
Spielberg camera moves and everything
it's interesting because you're not like
trying to frame up like an actual shot
per se you're just trying to get
everyone's performances like within the
camera so that you can play around with
them and move them later in post
so on camera this looks so stupid
because right now it's just like an
awkward static shot of these three
people in the same frame yeah can I just
see yeah totally because you said this
is like really goofy and feels really
weird let's see what happens when you
roll a tank here I'll let me stand over
your shoulder for a moment all right
yeah right over
it doesn't look like he's really playing
to the strengths of the software right
now the characters are overlapping a lot
there's they're interacting with each
other I you know look this is some you
know magical software but it doesn't do
everything I don't know if this
particular style was tested you know
what I'm saying like yeah we tested with
the live footage but like this whole
setup that they're doing right now is
totally unproven you don't know if it's
gonna work yeah so you're like crossing
your fingers right now basically you're
crossing your toes I'm crossing
everything right now I'm like 80 sure
it's gonna work if if it ends up being
the 20 I can always just spend three
years on it if it doesn't work we just
have to cut it probably right like if a
shot doesn't work it's not like there's
an option to just like animate it by
hand right because the whole goal of
this is to do it really quickly
I mean yeah but I'm I'm starting to get
the sense that I'm making you
uncomfortable no you'd never make me
uncomfortable am I saving a lot of work
for later right now no I mean how how
the hell else are we gonna get this shot
you know we gotta have somebody in a UFO
I don't see a UFO set around here
anywhere you gotta use the green screen
come on you know what Sam is right I
thought I learned my lesson after the
Spider-Man short film and then I thought
I'd learned my lesson after scooty but I
have yet to learn my lesson because what
am I gonna do not make it good screw
that I will do whatever it takes to make
it good
I don't know what I'm saying I wrote
this thing we shot it and I got a stick
see the idea so if that means I gotta
take a shot or two or 10 into blender
and do some custom work I'm gonna do it
I can make it in a week
I think
all right so we got everything shot got
it offloaded onto the computer I have
all the audio synced and everything
ready to go so I'm going to be diving
into this edit and I'm very excited so
let's see I got my drone shots here
which
is offline for some reason
Peter how's the edit
is this a good time
and it's incredibly important Sam you're
you're in my computer no one cares look
right now Mark's the 13th anniversary of
us starting this channel so we're going
to do something super special no way
what no oh I just said no way oh okay
see this cool shirt I'm wearing we've
embodied one of the most iconic moments
in video editing this shirt represents
the Blood Sweat and Tears that we've
gone through because it's red this shirt
is a limited edition shirt that's going
to be on sale right now for seven days
it's a limited edition run where can I
get this shirt Corridor Digital Dot
Store look there's something even more
important I have to tell you okay every
single person who purchases one of these
limited edition shirts is going to be
entered into a giveaway where you will
have a chance to win a ten thousand
dollar Puget systems workstation just
like the ones we are using in our studio
right now Dangs that's gonna be a nice
computer ten thousand dollars that's
crazy the point is we want to do
something super special because these 13
years have been super important to us
and we want to make sure that one of you
one of our lucky viewers can actually
have a super cool computer that's what
that's such a good deal how are we
staying afloat with this deal because
puget's paying for it this is coming out
of fugit's pocket that's great so how
did you get in my computer we're not
actually having a conversation you're
speaking to a pre-recorded video clip
well then I should probably just get
back to editing I'm going to delete this
Peter wait there's still more talking
points hold on I gotta get back wait
wait there's more talking points sorry
sorry sorry sorry
so last night I sat down and I designed
the characters for the piece I got a
space suit model from online but I
wanted a unique head for the characters
and so I started with just a basic blob
and I kept sculpting at it until it
looked right I'm really happy with this
character
look at the strike though you're going
to make two more characters well I mean
you just have to set up the one and then
slightly alter it to get the two more
that's a lot of work Rin how many times
have we had this conversation
time ever especially using Wonder
Dynamics I think you actually have a
shot at getting all of it done I think
it might be possible this time no yes
you're at least horrifying it that's
what you see that's what you come in on
and see oh that looks great actually
nevermind and that's something you
modeled yes rather than selecting the
pre-made ones it would save a lot of
time
what are we doing here is there a cut of
this thing yeah or anything like some of
it is cut I don't even some of it
that's exactly interesting okay how many
days does that leave you then for the
for the VFX Friday Saturday Sunday
Monday well that's great so I have four
days does this rig work with Wonder
Dynamics yep have you actually gotten it
to work with their system well the way
this facial tracking Works uh in the
software is based off of things called
blend shapes a blend shape can be
anything like left eyebrow up or right
cheek below then the way it animates the
Faces by blending in between those
different shapes so I still have to do
that which is
probably going to be a good amount of
work but how many blend chips are gonna
make
52. no no no you're not gonna make 52
you're gonna walk you're gonna finish
the cut make a list of the emotional
beats the characters go through and
you're gonna only make the blend shapes
of those emotions that's actually the
way to go for sure that's that's what to
do
I'm legitimately stressed out about
whether he can finish this in time
Sam
I won't let you down right I know you
won't it just well I mean I'm just
saying that
Sam I there will be a Blu-ray of
something on your desk on Tuesday I mean
I got the Blu-ray right here I just
gotta burn it someone will figure out
the burner situation we buried it God
dang it we buried it in the backyard
very briefly
[Music]
so I've been here all weekend what's
this video about
Matt you want to see something cool sure
Peter let's check it out okay cool I got
a lot of cool visual effects to show you
right now can't wait
okay so you know Wonder Dynamics they
got that alien but we don't want to use
their alien we want to use our custom
alien we want our custom Squish and I
have done some tests with the custom
Squish and I want to show you guys wow
yeah yeah it's all working look at this
look at the facial expressions no that's
what this smile is coming through the
blinking this question is such an
expressive character you need you need
all 52 blend shapes in there for sure I
did all 52. did you do all 50. I did all
dang 52 son and it was easy Sam tells me
lots of things to do it but you know who
has to make the decision me all right so
now that all the hard like character
modeling and sculpting and blend shape
stuff is done literally this is all I
need to do to get one of these shots
that's a shot right there's there's the
shot
scan frame for actors scanning
so which of us shall descend first I
volunteer squeebs it's so easy I can do
it I had full confidence that you're
going to do it I don't know if I believe
that but I'm I'm flattered honestly from
here it's smooth sailing I got the
characters ready to go just gotta load
those in load in some shots finish that
edit do some extra little VFX tweaks
here and there and uh there will be
something you can watch that is true I
mean we're watching something now too
yeah this is technically something to
watch so if you think about it really
I've already delivered on my promise I
believe in you buddy thanks
it's friendship
[Music]
foreign
we are right up on the line here but I
got some cool stuff so let's take a look
at it so it's not just wonder Dynamics
in this video I decided to be a smart
person and add extra work to a video
that already had a lot of VFX in it so
there's some traditional VFX shots like
the car smashing we don't have a rusty
car we don't have a UFO that can pick it
up and smash it against the ground so we
got to go on sketchfab find a rusty old
car we do some simulations on little
bits and Bobs so it feels like it
actually has some Physics to it when
it's lifting off the ground hit render
and we're good to go baby and I put a CG
spaceship in there what do you want what
do you want me to say I mean you know
what I did it's just your classic V
effect dude wish I could be spending my
time doing other things but who am I
going to take that up with me it's my
fault it's all my fault and I just have
to accept that and move through it all
right Dean get get out of here I need to
I need to get back to work what about
the Blu-ray did you find a Blu-ray
burner yet
I'll burn it to a Blu-ray and smack it
down on your desk I think they buried in
the backyard
all right
this is not here when the deadline hits
he has failed
that's a thousand year Arc for us to
live dude that's our home within a
thousand years
[Music]
thank you
did you finally finish it
a man of his word I'm proud of you thank
you Sam that means a lot
that's all
[Music]
Peter actually was able to pull it off
which is absolutely
mind-blowing he's taken something that
normally requires a lot of time energy
or money or manpower to accomplish and
has done it in an incredibly small
amount of time if he's trying to
accomplish something visually it feels
like there's nothing he can't do is the
tools whether it's an unreal thing
whether it's live action whether it's in
blender it's fully CG he's in that world
now of being able to accomplish his
vision but when you can do anything
what do you choose to do
at the end of the day it's not about how
cool your VFX are anymore it's the
challenge against yourself now that you
have released something what do you need
to refine and find ways to improve I
think that's that's what it really comes
down to so Peter's a special guy I look
forward to seeing anything he creates